[Musik]
erst stehen dann gehen das lernt man
früh israel der weg zur schule ist für
mehr auf kaspi und ihre drei töchter
entspannt bisher ist die familie gut
durch alle corona wellen gekommen die
eltern haben sich früh impfen lassen
jetzt sind die fünf bis elfjährigen dran
doch mehr aufzüge
mit den intensiv für die kinder erwarte
ich im moment lieber noch weil ich noch
nicht weiß was die auswirkungen sein
werden
mit den kindern warte ich und gehe kein
risiko ein
[Applaus]
obwohl kinder unter zwölf seit monaten
etwa 50 prozent aller neuinfektionen
ausmachen sind zu beginn der jüngsten
impfkampagne viele eltern zurückhaltend
mit ihrem immunsystem überstehen die
kinderleichte krankheit wir haben schon
viel erfahrung damit ich habe kein
problem ich selbst wegen alles impfen zu
lassen aber ich denke nicht dass sich
die kinder im moment impfen lassen wäre
im moment warte ich damit noch obwohl es
etwas gutes ist das macht man doch bei
allem was neues erwartest du erst einmal
um zu sehen wie es läuft nebenwirkungen
und dann entscheidest du
die impfung der kinder ist die letzte
große etappe in den bisher so
erfolgreichen feldzug gegen das virus
und vielleicht die schwierigste die
immer entschied die regierung schnell
und entschlossen von der freigabe des
impfstoffs in den usa bis zur ersten
impfungen israel vergingen gerade mal
drei wochen und die kinder die ins ins
zentrum von holen kommen sind tapfer
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich nicht mehr in quarantäne
wenn jemand bei mir im kindergarten
corona bekommt wir glauben bei einer
wissenschaft und sind überzeugt dass die
impfung sicher und effektiv ist
millionen von kindern dieses alters
haben sie in den usa bekommen es gab
also keinen grund mehr zu
auch als vor monaten die ersten
jugendlichen geimpft wurden dauerte es
bis die vorreiter die anderen überzeugen
konnten auf ihr jedenfalls hofft dass
seine freunde bald seinem beispiel
folgen
ich habe lange gewartet dass kinder in
meinem alter geimpft werden als es
losging habe ich gleich einen termin
gemacht denn ich will mit meinen
freunden spielen ins schwimmbad gehen
und ins kino
für mich ist bewiesen dass die impfung
funktioniert gerade hier in israel
wir waren das pilot land und wir haben
auf die kinder impfung gewartet sie ist
sehr wichtig viele kinder werden zurzeit
krank und man muss sie beschützen
die immunisierung der kinder gilt als
entscheidender schritt hin zur ersehnten
herdenimmunität der ganzen gesellschaft
auch wenn es dafür keine garantie gibt
ist es für mediziner der einzige weg
unser ziel ist gerade die kinder in der
altersgruppe 5 bis 11 zu impfen um die
mobilität der gesellschaft zu verstärken
ich weiß nicht ob wir dadurch schon
herdenimmunität erreichen da bin ich
nicht sicher aber je mehr kinder geimpft
werden desto geringer ist die gefahr
einer weiteren verbreitung der pandemie
dafür setzt ministerpräsident beck sogar
die impfung seines sohnes david
werbewirksam in szene
die impfung schützt unsere kinder ihre
eltern und ganz israel deswegen rufe ich
alle eltern in israel auf ihre kinder
impfen zu lassen
bennetts kurs ist unter den israelis
durchaus umstritten aber seine strategie
in der vierten welle war höchst
erfolgreich das öffentliche leben ging
fast ohne einschränkungen weiter es gab
keinen lockdown keine impfpflicht kein
zweig noch vor der internationalen
freigabe schrift die regierung ende juli
die dritte impfung an seither bekamen
vier millionen menschen den booster
knapp 45 prozent der bevölkerung
insgesamt sind nach angaben der
krankenkassen 90 prozent aller
erwachsenen über 16 jahre geimpft die
kassen versuchten gleich zu beginn
buchstäblich alle zu erreichen
wir haben den impfstoff für jeden
erreichbar und erhältlich gemacht indem
wir zum beispiel gezielt die ältere
generation angesprochen haben wir kamen
anfangs persönlich zu haus terminen bei
ihnen vorbei wo wir dann auch geimpft
haben dann kamen die anderen
altersgruppen
das war der schlüssel zum erfolg dieses
projekts
trotz aller erfolge in israel gibt es
auch grundsätzliche gegner der impf
politik allerdings sind die weniger
zahlreich als lautstark
und sie schrecken auch vor extremen
vergleichen nicht zurück der judenstern
der nazis als symbol ihrer gefühlten
diskriminierung
die anwältin rotem braun organisiert
selbst demos gegen die politik des
staates der beschneide die
menschenrechte der ungeimpften ist ruhe
die meinungsdiktatur
wenn dir deine regierung erzählt was
wahr ist dann musst du dich fragen warum
gibt es nicht mehr meinungen
welche länder kennen sie auf der welt
die nur eine wahrheit haben und nur eine
negativ
die meisten israelis revoltieren
allerdings nicht aus einsicht oder weil
sie von einer politik profitieren die
ihnen trotz des virus ein leben
weitgehend ohne einschränkungen
ermöglicht gerade steigen die
infektionszahlen wieder leicht vorerst
nur ein warenzeichen die menschen werden
weiter mit dem virus leben müssen nach
der welle ist vor der nächsten aber mit
einer entschlossenen corona politik
können die israelis der gelassener
entgegensehen
[Musik]